[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by grace caroline
curry formerly known as grace fulton who
plays becky in fall which is in theaters
friday how you doing today grace
oh i'm so good this is so fun
oh yeah i'm so excited to talk to you i
absolutely love this film it's so
intense too and
i think the biggest question people are
going to have coming out of this movie
is seeing that your character's getting
this 2 000 foot tv tower what is
actually happening here like on set like
how high are you really you got high
winds blowing on you what's actually
going on uh i mean it was absolutely
immersive we were we were out there in
the elements it wasn't a fan and a sound
stage
um i kind of wish it was but no i don't
uh yeah you know it was crazy and i
definitely have the the tan lines to
prove it it's it's pretty hilarious uh
because i'm very pale and uh uh the sun
was very intense in the summer
um but no we we were up uh on a on a
2000 foot cliff
uh in the desert out of uh victorville
um
a bit of a drive out from there in the
middle of nowhere i mean jenny popped a
tire maybe four or five times trying to
make it live we started carpooling
together in my good old honda crv
um but the the tower itself that was
built was uh about a hundred feet
um so ultimately we were
very high up
oh my god i see i really thought it was
gonna be a sound stage you're gonna say
so that's incredible
wow so d did you have any fear of
heights before this or any phobias in
general if you didn't
um you know when i was young i i had a
little bit of fear when rock climbing at
rei at their climbing wall you know kind
of stressed me out a little bit but
since then i've done some bouldering so
i had a little bit of experience with
um climbing up higher and i knew that my
palm starts sweating at a certain height
and my stomach gets a little
nauseous and uh suddenly i can't hear my
friends so well down below
um but i really didn't know how i was
going to feel being that high and being
on the tower
[Music]
until i was in it and i definitely
didn't tell scott that i might have any
fear but i did let him know i had some
bouldering indoor climbing gym
experience which i think was really
really helpful ultimately and um
i i teared up when i first got to the
top of the tower because it was just so
beautiful i wasn't scared i was in awe
um i think fear turned into just awe the
whole time to get to actually shoot out
there and
be in the environment
wow
i'm amazed i'm still just processing you
saying you're actually up on this high
tower that is so cool but that's really
cool that you're that brave because i
would be freaking out but no you you
crush it up there and that's so much
more impressive too that you did that
performance that high up so
what's also really special though about
this film is the relationship between
becky and hunter so once you knew that
virginia was going to be playing hunter
because this film's a two-hander and
that relationship's central to the story
what is the process from the first
day that you know okay it's me and it's
virginia how did you guys go about
building that trust um well even before
i knew it was gonna be ginny i got a
couple names for the chemistry read um i
kind of
i kind of
worked it to get a chemistry read going
because i i got to meet with scott
beforehand and he uh sent the script out
to actors and asked them you know who
who do you respond to more hunter becky
and i i responded to becky moore and he
definitely agreed um he's like yeah
you're a becky
um but but i i told him how much i hate
auditioning
and and he went well you know it is a
two-person job maybe a chemistry read is
a better situation i was like definitely
um and then i get sent a couple actors
um that i'm gonna be reading with and i
i messaged them on instagram to see if
they wanted to rehearse the scenes
beforehand
and prepare something for scott
um and ginny responded within minutes
and we actually facetimed twice two days
ahead like
two days separately before our
zoom um
and uh
i mean she
i think there was a lot of compatibility
initially between us with our work ethic
and
even our interpretation of
hunter and becky which is why we got
cast
but no i mean we we uh i hung out at at
ginny's and we drank some wine and
before we shot and but the whole
experience itself i mean we were going
back to our rooms rehearsing scenes
eating mac and cheese
and uh
talking about what did we get ourselves
into
yeah i mean and it shows on screen
though how like
you feel how real this relationship is
and it's awesome to hear that you took
that extra prep that early that's really
cool and
i saw an article today too about this
deep fake mouth movement to remove
cussing in the film so how much cussing
were you two doing up there exactly were
you guys cursing like sailors up there
what the hell was going on i mean there
were some sailor mouse i remember
telling my parents and going oh gosh
guys i don't know there's a lot of
swearing this i don't know if you're
gonna like it you know a couple of
sailors um but you know scott's english
um
ginny's very vocal
uh
and i'm in the you know the midst of it
so why not you know and but scott also
would you know feed us a couple f-bombs
here and there and uh
we went okay aye aye captain here we go
i love that um yeah that's so cool but
it's so cool the technology like because
it's not noticeable at all it's pretty
and that must freak you out in a way too
because it's your mouth that's getting
changed right like yeah that's flawless
yeah i i mean when scott told me
uh we did a little bts interview
recently and he goes you know
uh we and he started sharing how much
they were utilizing the flawless
technology i didn't know what he was
talking about because i had seen that
and
as far as i knew my mouth was making all
the movements that
i had made it make and he's going oh
yeah we had to take out so much
swearing and um oh yeah we no we applied
the technology and i was like
what
wow
yeah
that's that's amazing there's so many
things right now blowing my mother's
movie so it's getting excited to watch
it again now too and
uh it's interesting because you're this
big star of a movie coming out now and
it's got to be exciting for you because
you have that experience with shazam
where you have this movie star moment
uh do you have any rituals for opening
weekend for you do you go and see it
with your family on the big screen like
what are you doing this weekend when the
film comes out
oh gosh that's such a good question and
it's so funny that you're saying it's a
big star moment because oh goodness i've
been doing this since i was four years
old and it's always looked different
when some things come out you just sort
of like
are are going along with the flow of
whatever comes up um
i i am gonna go see it with a big group
this weekend
um because i mean
when you watched it did you watch it
alone or did you get to watch it with
someone else i watched it sadly by
myself but it was still cool in that
experience
oh but that's cool you know i i didn't i
haven't gotten to watch it alone so i
don't know what that's like but um the
group really holy cow just
escalates everything right oh okay yeah
so i'll i'll be seeing it with the group
this weekend um
and
honestly i i i kind of just sit back
when this sort of stuff happens i'm like
well see i hope people enjoy it i don't
know
oh no they're gonna love it you're gonna
have another hit on your hands which is
awesome and
it's awesome too now that you're gonna
play also the superhero version of mary
and shazam fury the gods who's coming
out on christmas so when inevitably your
funko pop comes out of you are you gonna
get that and are you someone gonna go
wild with the merch like are you excited
about stuff like that oh yes oh yeah i'm
i'm a little bit of a nerd so i think i
might cry if something gets made of my
superhero form
um i might cry now just even thinking
about it i mean my my brother and i were
like a heavy action figure
um notice i call them
i
action
figures
uh
heavy heavy on the action figures in
this household i mean we have an entire
uh tupperware of jurassic park action
figure stuff i mean we got like all
sorts of stuff so
um i think
yeah i i i'll definitely be getting that
oh great this is good so breaking you
know grace caroline curry is a nerd this
is great to confirm here um but
everybody watch grace caroline curry
just murder it here in fall it is out
friday go see it in theaters it is so
much fun it's so intense and it's a
tribute to your amazing performance
grace thank you so much for joining me
today and i'll talk to you in the future
thank you so much thank you